[Music]
[Music]
this is the chiliad Mountain State
wilderness within it lies a variety of
animals yet one reigns supreme in Latin
it is known as the village kokoro - the
silent raise people's it is known by
many names including cougar Panther and
Puma it is the Lion of the mountain
it is here in the Pulido forest at the
line calls at home this female lion is
most certainly hungry no it's not most
of a day spent here perched on a high
ground surveying the woods for prey some
nearby rabbits is a start she begins her
approach Kathlyn bird we gone a good
kill yet a rabbit is finger food for
this 180 pound lion
she'll need something bigger you think
the local deer would be an excellent
source of food yet recent events
conclude that we see how to increase the
agility to simply put is a racist the
lion
rare is really sweet the lion turns
Testament
maybe another source 15 people first
hikers here intend to explore the
wilderness start exploring
it's once again centroids habitat is
changing local park rangers have been on
the rise independent and in turn pushing
the night into here we see our female
beginning the long journey that every
young lion must embark on
using her keen senses she speed-dials
the downtown cab company and gets a lift
to the big city this one time Lacey
Jones got in the back of my cab i
Shekinah she did like six lines and coke
in the back there
[Music]
as expected the long journey has made
her hungry a convenient snack
let's get you why yet no life in Los
Santos is a cheap one here I'm G by the
opening at the vanilla unicorn adopting
her feline mounting screws yeah she
grates for the climbs on the catwalk in
hopes of attracting the resident males
let me get a buddy yo an ass here can't
approach goes unnoticed she presents
herself the male frost any the male
expresses satisfaction looking you've
not only a successful night but a
successful beginning
but
[Music]